[Music]
one reason I watch the Superbowl is I
love the big commercials I think that's
the reason a lot of us check it out I
love the big commercials the problem is
I have a very tiny bladder so I'm
constantly going to the bathroom it's
just something I was born with you know
through I your innate every eight
seconds yeah
I've urinated several times during this
monologue yep because of that because
I'm always leaving the room I miss half
the commercials well now it's too bad I
mean you're you're a big star I can't
you just get somebody to send over the
commercials the Superbowl ad so you can
just watch them before the game I can't
do that who's gonna show me the ads
ahead of time that's not gonna happen
oh come on you're Conan O'Brien if you
get any celebrity who's in one of the
Superbowl commercials to just come by
and show you the ad I just I know they I
don't think they would do that of course
they would hey Kim Kim comes your car in
your commercial
[Applause]
Kim Kardashian wears well
uau did a Super Bowl ad I did and of
course I'll show it to you I'll show to
you right now here is the world premiere
of my Super Bowl commercial hi I'm Kim
each month millions of gigs of unused
data are taken back by wireless
companies tragic data you paid for that
can be used to see my makeup my back and
my outfits my vacations and my outfits
sadly I lost please help save the data
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah never kardashian-west everybody
thank
[Applause]
you